it just expressed so much frustration
that in the case of yet another black
woman in this country
there was no charges brought but rather
only a charge for endangering
her neighbors hillary veteran he's been
in the league for seven years he came
over in the
night jay crowder trade but has hardly
played
played a little bit in the bubble as
tyler hiro banks at home ler's thinking
pass more than score so he stayed into
the roll lane
and was able to deflect the ball tyler
hero
he played over 30 minutes in that game
three
said he was gassed after the first five
minutes
hero nice fake to get rid of tatum and
then knocks it down how about this 20
year old hero doing it again for the
heat
there's a knock down shooter and playing
with extreme confidence right now 31-28
heat with a three-point advantage hero
lost it got it back turns shoots and
scores
tyler hero 11 points in nine minutes and
he forces brad stevens to call
timeout no fear whatsoever well he comes
off to score every time
picks up the loose ball still things
shot
he's averaging almost eight rebounds a
game in the series
and banks that one beautifully and they
ran a double flare on that one from the
side out
tyler hero again tyler hero from
downtown
he's got 18 points to lead all scores
and they ran a double flare on that one
from the side out
tyler hero again tyler hero from
downtown they're down by 12 now it's
two hero little euro step flips it up
and then wow
tyler hero with a superb move crowded
gets the finishing how about this play
by
tyler truly playing good players uh
you're not expecting it to be easy all
the way through we just need our best
quarter
in this quarter they have been able to
break the zone a little bit more in this
second half
what do you do with that maybe we go man
we'll see thank you so much eric back to
you mike
all right thank you rachel and right on
cue open up driving lanes
that driving lane was created by tice
hiro
feeling it in and out and in again
she knew he could shoot the basketball
but the surprising thing is how
comfortable he is
running the point guard position has
size and versatility
so you can utilize him in a variety of
ways
leads all players in the playoffs in
minutes per game at 40 per game
hiro fires away puts it in tyler harrow
drills another three
smart drives deflected another turnover
here on the fourth for the celtics
heroes got it hiro drives reverse banks
at home
he's got 30. i mean like
mark was saying just good pace good
rhythm good use of the
rim hero with seven to shoot
hiro long three-pointer bang tyler 33
points on 13 of 19 from the field
at this time out they have to give him
an honorary
he's holding on to it on the far side of
the court you can see him fallon
extended
jimmy butler four to shoot backing in
backing in
feet inside hiro with a left hand